supply shortages could be forcing your
favorite restaurant to tweak its menu a
little bit some are scrambling for
substitute items others just crossing
off certain dishes victoria saha spoke
to a few restaurants in her area and she
joins us now live from summerlin with
more victoria
yeah las vegas has such a huge food
scene it's hard to imagine walking into
your favorite restaurant and seeing some
items crossed off on the list but some
restaurants like lola's here in
summerlin are doing their absolute best
to make sure customers are happy
the kitchen staff at lola's is finding
their way around not being able to use
their key ingredients i dream a lot of
things but this is not one of them that
i would ever have put together
at this authentication restaurant their
signature dishes require special
ingredients straight from louisiana like
andui sausage and ladenheimer bread this
is the original leidenheimer bread they
just got their shipment in this week but
for a while
they went without the problem now is
they don't know when the next shipment
will come in you go to that restaurant
to get that favorite dish if it's not
available it's so disappointing and i
don't want to disappoint my guests which
is why owner lola pocorni is trying to
see if local bakers can get the job done
it's been a good substitute but
nothing is ever going to be lightning
hummer many reasons for the supply
shortage are connected to worker
shortages which leads to delivery issues
and recent hurricanes in louisiana
at some wolfgang puck restaurants you
might be seeing lamb chops crossed off
the menu we don't want to just keep
raising prices we try to
try to limit the
hit to ourselves and try not to pass on
the increase to the customers
restaurants are doing their best to
adjust to the never ending surprises
this pandemic brings
back here at lola's the owner says she's
giving herself four weeks to make sure
the supply issues are fixed if not she's
literally going to take things into her
own hands and start making that special
sausage in-house victoria zaha live
local now